was kind of the knitting battle and uh
gabriel ramani he
had like a rap song and this and that
and that and this
on the phone as well and a couple of
other chefs have called me and talked
and so on and so forth you know from
there i think
good things came out of it and we can
see that
there's been a discussion around this
issue don't
attack each other don't be hostile
towards each other well i it's not
correct let's advise one another we're
trying to do
something for the dean to the best of
our capabilities let's try to understand
each other
if there's clear battle clear-cut button
and you advise a person in private and
you continue and they do it then the
the the dean calls us if it's done in
public
you should now refute important
check out our sponsors nature's blend
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products so one
more thing
before uh before we conclude so i'm just
teaching my children how to knit i
learned to knit when i was six years old
and i remember
the moves in round out and off
in round out and off and now my kids are
learning
i just got them a set of knitting
needles and some huge wool
and we said let's go for it mashallah
you know mikki and zinji can have a
little blanket or two
and inshallah we can also spend our time
a little bit constructively so that's
that's round that's off so in
round out and off in
round out and off and that's the last
one in round out and off that's 20
stitches
and let's see how far we've gotten
masha'allah there goes ooh
there we getting there mashallah see
that was kind of the knitting battle and
uh
uh gabriel ramani he had like a rap song
and this and that and that and this was
kind of the knitting battle and uh
gabriel romani he had like a rap song
and this and that and that and this
so and i want to show here how two
brothers
they can disagree on some things right
but they can still love each other for
the sake of allah you follow me
so of course we don't we we agree on
something that is more powerful than
that that's the tohi that's the pure
monotheism right and to avoid [ __ ]
to avoid that this angers god almighty
allah and you're going to have within
families you're going to have people who
let put their hands up here put their
hands up there you disagree on some
some political interests down here but
at the end of the day you come together
your family
right so you two are family you can
disagree on some things but at the end
of the day you agree on something much
stronger than all that
so what was the kind of contention here
that you guys wanted to uh
uh or you wanted to clarify and maybe
some misunderstanding or something
to be honest i wanted to stop gabriel
maybe if we can just maybe
just tell us what like for example what
he didn't express it in the videos but
like it would be nice if he can tell us
like what was
going through his mind like the
frustration that he had because the
thing is it's very important
when it comes to these matters of
muslims disagree with each other
you know a lot of the time sometimes we
need to put ourselves into the other
person's shoes
you know there might be some
disagreements but you know like we need
to have
love towards the believers it's very
important in the uk and
we have a big problem of certain groups
maybe you don't want me to mention them
you know uh but they're they're very
hostile towards the believers
very very hostile physically uh in
intellectually in all angles you know
we've seen uh how they treat the
believers how they treat the muslims
and with me it's not like that you know
just because i disagreed with brother
gabriel on a certain
subject i don't automatically be like oh
you know i don't like this guy
and you know and we have this attitude
you know sadly this the lifestyle that
we live in you know everything is irre
we will replace it easily you know
amazon prime i don't like i'll do the
next one
um you know it's we have this attitude
and we implement it with our friends
and muslims as well he does something to
annoy me i've never seen any good from
him
he's finished this is a wrong attitude
that's the reason why i came to the uh
the dean's show because
you know brother gabriel is a believer i
love him for the sake of allah i don't
have
any kind of animosity towards him we can
disagree we'll talk about that
and we will leave it at that but it's
not like oh i don't like gabriel now
brother gabriel doesn't like mufti magna
mufti
doesn't like him and we don't like it
this is no we have to talk about these
matters we're believers we love each
other we want the best for the ummah
we're coming from different angles so um
i just want to
start gabriel if you can just just from
his you know what's discussed there but
maybe just to give a
what happened you know etc could you
deal with clients cetera what happened
and then maybe just elaborate and
educate the muslim youth
on how to deal with disagreements um and
you know
where we're coming from
yeah so exactly i mean i did speak with
uh multi-bank on the phone as well
and a couple of other shares have called
me and talked and so on and so forth you
know from there i think
good things came out of it and we can
see that
there's been a discussion around this
issue i think
people need to understand that there was
no
nitpicking i was not picking on knitting
or
i was not picking necessarily on
multimec as a figure i was
putting or picking on maybe what he was
representing
not only in the video there's a couple
of others that have been pointed out
a few times and it's been over the years
actually
i'm just so people understand the
background i don't have anything against
him personally or anything like that
we talked and so on uh you know we gave
each other our advice
and so on i cannot disclose to what we
talked and what not but we just you know
kind of gave each other advice
background that i was comfortable i
reviewed my video yesterday again i i
know that was a bit hot and you know
a few different shares told me okay
maybe you could have said this in a
different tone and so on
obviously these days um it is it is uh
sensitive people get upset and whatnot
and i agree i think my tone sometimes i
get a bit passionate
um but you know also you have to
understand when you deal with you know
people from all over who are falling
into
this trap of and i'm not saying he's
putting a trap or anyone else what i'm
saying is there is a trap out there
to emasculate men to make them more
feminine
and so on so when that happens where you
see
the products of this not necessarily
that an activity is haram necessarily
you know this is haram that is how and
what is
kind of what that might be interpreted
as
and it's not only about knitting i don't
want to bring up the other things
because i want to start again another
issue
okay i have and others have also talked
to him and
highlighted some of his other posts um
so it has nothing to do with that and
nothing to do with disrespecting
um i looked through the video again
again it was my tone maybe
i think i mentioned a kid who i'm going
to refute a kid and i think maybe people
thought i'm calling him a kid no it was
another video
of a kid a child given within one of
their lectures
so i was not calling him a kid or stuff
i would never do that and that's not my
way i've been taught by my shifts never
to disrespect
okay the people of knowledge in the guys
even if i disagree with them
okay yes i know that my tone was a bit
tough but um you know i mean
it is a huge issue i didn't call him as
not being a real man or anything like
that because i know you've highlighted
some of his achievements masha'allah
all i said is basically even if you're
going right now to a lot of these videos
and posts
um that you know we should someone of
his stature of his
mashallah follow it could be a bit more
balanced in posting a little bit more
about
maybe husband's rights about respect for
husbands right now i have a case today
this morning where the woman punched the
husband in the face during a flight in
the airplane in the
face man and there's you know it's just
i want to be the
boss i'm them you're not a man this and
that uh and you'd be like what
what does that have to do with this guy
it's not having to do it
it's a bigger picture i think people
restricted it to the knitting and to
follow
you know it's not to do with that is
that
i believe we need to bring about this
issue a bit more to talk about
the emascularization of man we need to
have more activities they're a bit more
conducive towards building real men
and i think the chefs and the guys have
to talk a little bit more
a little bit more about this to balance
it out
the jokes with you know like you know
the woman is the law
with the you know the happy wife happy
life these kind of things right it's
good it's nice it's cute and so on i
understand that
men should treat their lives better
there's a lot of bad men out there as
well
who mistreat their women and i
appreciate you know the people
highlighting those issues and trying to
teach men to be
softer towards their wives no doubt this
is the student of the prophet saw
but the prophet you know also raised
right that he was fighting battles he
was a real man he was strong and so on
people made it about knitting it was not
about knitting it was not about picking
on someone
is it's a bigger issue it's the issue
that right now if you look and you are
too
pick amongst the people who are doing
dawah how many
people are actually raising some of
these issues being lgbtq and how they
are happy that we talked about it today
um i know ali keeps it real and a lot of
his videos
i've seen i've been following ali for a
long time
you know being on the street there on
the ground right it's not behind a desk
or behind the
notice lecturing so that i appreciate
you know what i mean is a lot of real
stuff going on
i think we just need a bit more we need
to talk about a bit more
real issues and when i talked mostly
explained to me as to
why sometimes he might not do it and
this and that
i disagree with him i advise them and
that's pretty much it
you know one thing that sometimes i get
hate on his world is and i think
and this is what i'm trying to
understand you know the reason why i
wanted to elaborate on this topic is
because
the thing is the ummah needs to
understand that
different people give different styles
of dawah yeah and i believe your one is
more like
cut throat and i believe oma needs that
it's definitely something that
we definitely need it's cutthroat it's
needed and it's something
within my style as well where i like to
be like that as well i like to be
cut throat sometimes you know i like to
get to the point
and i think it needs it as well but i
think sometimes what happens is like
are you still at once your brother um
and the sheet artist
yes yeah so basically once i remember i
was at an event and omarisa was
performing
and you know his machine style is a bit
different yeah it's it's it's a bit
different
and there was a brother and he was like
oh look at this brother you know this
soft voice feminine voice
this time i was like you're actually
backed by him you know you're in front
of me you're back by the guy
you know and i was like aki look he does
his style
it doesn't make it haram yeah you might
not like it
you might not like the style okay i
agree with you you might say you know
what it's not for me i can say
some of all my sins in this sheets are
not for me some of them i love some of
them they're not just from me
it doesn't make him wrong it doesn't
make what he's doing
like when i look at the bigger picture
like i've recently i got into doing a
skits yeah
so for example i do certain skits and
some people come in and say to me
you know what this is is this the dawah
is etc and i was thinking
look my if i'm using a specific style
yeah okay now you might think that and
when i mean you i'm not talking about
brother gabriel or brother eddie i'm
talking in general the person
if this if it doesn't fit your style or
you don't like it or some people say
it's cringe
some people message me said bro you know
that was a big crunch i said may allah
bless
i appreciate i know when i was doing it
and watching it it was cringe for me to
edit it i was
i was cringed out myself watching myself
but the objective that i was trying to
get out
if i sometimes you know we have this
thing of you know i will fight for the
sake of allah you know i will do this
for the sake of allah
well can we sometimes be cringe for the
sake of allah
sometimes it's not about ego it's not
about what people i don't care what
people think about me you get it they
can say it's cringe
if i'm doing something that's
permissible i'm using a
style in the tower i shouldn't get
attacked for that people were attacking
me
like why are you doing this etcetera
this no i said yaki is that haram no
okay that's the preference if you don't
like it why are you discrediting what i
do
because it doesn't fall into your
preference or your style because some
brothers are
ragged they like to stop a bit you know
cut bro
but if some other diet is not doing it
that way is it
fair is it fair to have a go at them
for not doing it the way you deem it
should be
this this is why i think it's good yeah
that's a good point um
look the thing is abby the thing is um i
never said it
so that's clear i never said that it's
impermissible
brothers brought the issue of you know
idris
sometimes you know they had he had
weaving plates
you know and so and i said that's fine i
mean you know i think within the
first five minutes i mentioned
sewing his clothes and mending his shoes
in my video i've mentioned it three
times that i checked it in the first
five minutes
because i knew that and and still people
that's all they read in the
or wrote in the comments they're in the
process and you know source codes i'm
like guys listen man it's like
three times i've mentioned um the thing
is with the different styles
ali is uh allah
the prophet was soft and he was strong
the prophet
was a balance in sam cameron so if we
follow a strategy for islam
and for our dawah he is the one and only
that we should look for of course we
look at the sahaba as well yeah you
would have
he taught that to his men to his
companions i agree that there's a softer
approach sometimes
but there's a context i agree that
there's a stronger approach sometimes
and there's a context
i don't think i'm cut throat because if
you look through my videos there's a lot
of intellectual stuff
i talk about education i talk about all
kinds sometimes yes i do get hot
sometimes i'm a bit
different it depends not necessarily
cutthroat
but i think we have to have a company my
only contention was that
i understand this style i'm just saying
can he do a bit more
being in a position of your fears of so
much influence
where we have so many problems in this
world that the community that follows
him
a lot a big large community are
suffering from these issues
and he can make a huge with a small pose
a huge difference in maybe teaching men
how to be better to device okay fine
i see but also teaching women how to be
a bit more respectful to their husbands
a bit more careful towards their
households and their children and so on
a bit maybe uh a bit more aware as to
the lgbt agenda what's happening with
the schools because a lot of these
people have children in schools and so
on
and i brought up the issue of muruga i
just felt that for a person of his
statute was just not appropriate
and that's why he said he said that if i
knew
that drinking cold water would tarnish
my mood i would only
drink warm water right he just has the
statement i can send you the statement
arabic
it's just about one of the the
requirements in the muslim
hadith we're accepting that it's not
wrong okay it's not
wrong to it's not haram to drink this
water that
is just how people might perceive it and
is it
something that someone of the statute i
would just say that he could do a little
bit more balance i understand that it's
different style but i think the
processing had the comprehensive style
there was sometimes a bit of harshness
or strength or let's say firmness even
in this hot pass to the point that
you get red and so on when you talk
about certain things and sometimes you
find him crying and his beard wet and
subhanallah you know
just touching an orphan's head and just
dealing with the children
so beautiful when you just softens your
heart you know that's pretty much
what i was trying what i'm what i'm
trying to make but i think
work living in the 21st century the
challenges that we are facing right now
2021
with all the new laws that have been
passed by all the
new push the new curriculum people just
got a lock down
i understand that okay spend time with
the children but
let us look also at other things as well
because there's a lot of issues that we
can address and people in power and that
mashallah influence can really influence
the people
can really that the indian pakistani
community has huge
problems with gallery with abuse with
this um
sorry ali you know in london i have many
of my clients from london
the streets of london somalis are
stabbing each other and the pakistanis
are stabbing each other drugs
and so many problems man you guys have
so many issues in that community
subhanallah
and people don't understand what's
happening on the streets of london you
know uh you know i talked to parents you
know
i had a sister whose son got stabbed you
know the kids were coming to our door
trying to stab with the son
it's it's not a joke people are a need
to understand there's a lottery
i think a lot of these people might
might
having instagram facebook they might be
scrolling and seeing a video
of multiman or whoever and they'll be
like oh brothers you know let's
do this brothers don't do that it's not
just about let's love each other but
also
the process of selling says that i
i i the sabbah used to ask the person
about the good things i used to ask them
about the bad things
you know like we need to balance it out
if you make a video like guys don't do
that guys this is not correct guys
you know let's be a bit more this thing
you can reach like a huge
ar are you are you are you saying i've
heard you talk about like
uh gabrielle like for instance if you if
we talk about people talk about
uh the rights you know that islam gave
for the muslim woman
you know that she is to be honored
cherished respected
uh you know and then you quote the
hadith from the last final message
you know the best of you are those who
are best of their wives
uh so you know to to live with them on a
footing of kindness of mercy you know
this is just clear but at the same time
are you saying to be balanced like you
also have if you're if you're
instructing the man there like many men
like hold on
but what about you know if you also
where the righteous women are devoutly
obedient and straightened
from the quran then you also should you
be balanced and quoting the hadith
that are also talking about if i would
if i would have ordered anyone to make
sajdah i would order the wife to her
husband
uh also you know just there's so many
about when the woman
these things have to be explained and
educated educated so is that
is that what you're saying like watch
your attitude because your husband is
your paradise to your hellfire right so
we don't hear a lot of these but it's
just like okay keep it balanced
is that what you're saying there's a
reactionary movement right now obviously
because no doubt has been some men who
just didn't do things right
and but but the solution to that is not
to empower necessarily
women beyond what allah is in partner
with you know because right now there's
a
there's so don't don't those bombs don't
represent
the actual illustration of islam if they
if they misrepresented they're not kind
they're
don't like take the exception to the
okay exactly that's not the solution so
i think
right now there's a there's a
reactionary movement on the other side
where women are being empowered if you
look at
as i said if you look at the female or
the female
you know are given dawah they keep
talking about women empower yourself
take care of your body go to the gym
uh you know learned martial i was just
looking uh today someone said you know
they're like mashallah doing kickboxing
all kinds of things
uh you know the women are mashallah you
know being told go out
be independent you keep hearing these
things and the shepherds are promoting
that look at their
uh their social media not that i'm just
looking to check i know people like or
you're looking at that
it's it's people clients people forward
things to me
i do check i check um look at their
speeches look at what they're talking
about
how many are saying hey sister let's sit
at home and take care of our children
because they're being put into schools
for eight hours or in front of a screen
now for 10 hours or whatever
and they're being conditioned you know
and then you're like what's wrong with
my son why does he have this and that
so uh you know but where is the sheikh
has the sister
guys you know who are teaching the women
to hey
you know let's um take care of our
household let's uh talk about some
ethics that teach our kids in the house
let's
uh you know respect our husbands let's
uh maybe you know
dress a bit better when the husband
comes outside from the fitnah that he
can actually look at something nice when
he comes in because that's his
uh all i'm saying is let's let's bring
back the sunnah
being balanced if you want to talk about
females rights and empowerment let's
talk about men's rights and empowerment
if you want to talk about
feminine and listen let's talk about
masculinity right and and
and bottom line is the the man the man
is the imam of the house there's no if
ands and buts about it as much as people
are going to try to
go left and right and back and center
the man is the imam of the house
that is not just like i want to beat
myself in the chest haha we want it's
about responsibility accountability
it's about a lot of things that a man
has to carry on his shoulder
going back to the quran understanding
these things educating the community
we'll solve our problems keep inflating
the women empowering him and giving that
and deflating the man you know
smaller weaker yeah it's allowed to so
it's a lot to this you know but the
women are talking about kickboxing the
women are talking about raising their
fists in there the women are demanding
the rights the women are pushing to go
out
and work and wear pants and you know
do whatever and i don't dance in front
of people and play basketball in front
of people and whatnot
now that there's anything wrong with
haram with that swan i don't say that
all i'm saying is look at the different
approaches empower
get strong this and that here not so
much because we have to be careful not
to be
ali yeah what do you want before we
conclude what do you want to say i think
that's that's why when i did the video i
i agreed with where you're coming from
your concerns you know
and sadly when you do these videos
people were sending attack towards you
and then sending an attack towards mufti
and then i was getting some attacks as
well and is that look man
we're not here we're trying to reason
we're not just because i did a video it
doesn't mean
i was just like and i don't know why
people do that
i heard that you're going to lose your
job and i was very disturbed by that i
was like why would you lose your job
you know this is prophetic you know and
and the thing is just because i disagree
with the execution brother of gabriel
done
i knew where he was coming from i'm 100
with him it's just the execution and i
do that sometimes
and we almost we all make mistakes but
the thing is to someone to lose their
job
for someone to get hate yeah people
sending you hate uh by muslims
look we don't this attitude is a cultish
behavior yeah
okay we love brotherhood we love brother
gabriel brother eddie
but if i make a mistake because it's
alibaba who the hell is what do you mean
if i make a mistake you tell him brother
he was wrong not no we've seen good work
yes okay
you've seen good works it's not good for
us to cross out cancel somebody
just because a mistake would deem them
to be to make
and this is society we live inside do
you make one mistake people forget about
you
that shouldn't be the case you know but
i just see as for example like with
mufti men even like for example the
danish interview
i i believe like he's already we can see
he's already under pressure
yeah yes some things he said i i can
understand because
he's under pressure and he wants to open
his door to taheed
around the world he doesn't want it to
be limited in different areas now that
can be argued
but whenever i think about this it
reminds me of the treaty of hodeidah
and when surah was revealed yeah the
sahaba on the on their way to do um
hajj yeah they got they're on their way
they're being stopped
they're being offered a a a agreement
that
if you heard today certain brothers um
well like they would lose their mind can
you imagine that you're being told
you're going to hand off the hand over
the believing men
to the mushriks you're going to have
them over to the mushriks
and then on top of that the ones you
become who leave islam you send them
back
and if if muslims from here travel to
you you i mean
you're going to send them back and so
the agreement was like
and then allah sent the revelation and
he says we've given you a clear victory
the sahaba were like what clear victory
so in the moment
we think sometimes it's like this
doesn't make sense and it's it's
we are we're finished uh in putting
muhammad jab's word you know you are
finished you know you're finished
you're finished yeah we're literally
finished but the hikmah behind it and
even though kind of vocalizing his thing
against the prophet salallahu
and the companions not listening to the
prophet peace be upon him sometimes
there's
wisdom in certain things that are being
done and we have to even though from the
outside it's like
rough seriously like it might make you
cringe you might be like what the
hell we need to sometimes i believe look
at the bigger picture
with what brother gabriel is doing
brother muftimenk is doing brother eddie
is doing or what i'm doing on muhammad
hijab whatever it may be
we shouldn't as muslims have hostility
towards each other because it's sad to
see
that the consequences of that is that
brother gabriel might lose his job or
get death threats and
get an attack and then i'm getting
attacked and then why should it be like
that let's understand brother gabriel is
coming from a place
of genuine concern and brother mufti
meng is coming from a genuine concern
we all are we're just trying to fight
the same battle in different means
and the reason why i wanted to do this
is to touch up on that muslims
don't attack each other there's no hymn
against me we're all that don't
turn against somebody just because you
disagree that's the reason why i wanted
to do this segment
to emphasize on that not emphasize on
the whole knitting thing etc brother
gabriel's cl
made qualifications what the image made
clarification i'm making further
clarifications
it's just brothers if we just disagree
or our sisters don't attack each other
don't be hostile towards each other well
why
it's not correct let's advise one
another we're trying to do something for
the dean to the best of our capabilities
let's try to understand each other if
there's clear battle clear-cut
batting and you advise a person in
private and you continue
and they do it then the the re the dean
calls us if it's
done in public you should now refute in
public i i understand that that was it
well that's all i wanted to
say okay so alhamdulillah i'm very happy
elated that uh we got both of you
brothers together we cover
covered a lot and uh inshallah we can we
can do it again
jazakallah thank you both uh my brothers
it was really nice to
have you both on the dean's show
jazakallah may god almighty allah reward
both of you preserve you protect you
inshallah we can do this again sometime
thank you salaam alaikum
right now